remember um as the reference she helps
you see and as we've developed if you
have simple harmonic motion we kind of
have defined it as motion that's
harmonic but it's simple because a
single sine or cosine wave gives you the
motion gives you that up and down
oscillating fluctuating whatever you
want to call it okay that's what makes
this simple however there are other ways
that you can write simple harmonic
motion that don't look like they're a
single silent or cosine wave but they
really are in disguise the question then
becomes why would you do that I'm
hopefully going to demonstrate for you
why that would be useful ok so I'm going
to two examples easy one and a hard one
here's the easy one if you think about
what the standard form of simple huh by
motion is help me write it however usual
oh and whatever you want to call it
could be an X not be V would not be
actually any other kind of constant plus
some lot of this right and of course you
can substitute in cosine or you might
have a minus sign instead of class but
you get that's the general form okay in
the question I look here this is 12
moderator which I think I signed they
give you this this is the question their
displacement equation is somewhat
different it looks like this guy okay so
this does not look like simple harmonic
motion but because of what we know with
trig identities it is okay so I want you
to remember now to be fair the question
itself which is this i'll be giving it
to you in hold your hand a little bit
okay a little bit what i want to do is
convert this into i don't want to have
that square there I don't mind any
coefficient of T that you like that can
be 2 4 6 8 whatever but I don't want
that square so what identity shall are
you
I should use double angle okay now so
that I can few get confused as to tease
or half tease or 40s or whatever I'm
just going to stick double angle in its
normal form that looks like this cos 2
theta is equal to ok now it's easier to
get the signs it's easy to get the signs
wrong like is it 1-2 cause whatever or
is it to Kozma so to help you remember
what I always appeal to is just go back
to the original one go back to this guy
this is where the form that you're
talking about this is where it comes
from and it's quite hard to get this one
wrong most people get this one right we
know that cos square plus sine squared
is 1 cos squared minus sine squared okay
we've got that ok so from there I'm just
going to get everything in cos squared
so I'll get rid of this guy yeah so
that'll turn into cos squared take away
1 minus cos square using that pipeline
engineer I just mentioned and now you
can see oh that double negative that's
why it's too cos squared take away one
like causes always very awesome person
whatever whatever works for you like I
said this is the strategy I I am sort of
settled on so I've got that how am I
going to use that here what am I gonna
do okay so hold on a second I've got a
I've got some number of closed squares
over here so the first thing I'm gonna
do is make cos squared the subject of
this I don't mind leaving is to
consequent because in fact i have 2 cos
square here but i will put that 1 plus 2
cos theta over there does that make
sense did I not sorry I think it's just
dim I think it's just dimmed that's all
it's just super dude because I'm running
low that's all yeah ok now at this point
at this point now I talk about this like
is it three t5t whatever I don't want to
get confused between this double angle
and that double angle so I'm just going
to say you feed our is 2t okay if I even
running if theta equals 2t then I'm
going to get 1 plus cos what
it equals squared which is the thing I
wanted yep okay I'm ready change the
color back I'm really actually now work
with this thing I've got three take away
now that's my to close squared to team
yeah so I'm just going to go 1 plus cos
for tea like so and let's see what have
I got here three take my 12 and that's a
negative cause for tea Annabel don't do
it right first question yeah okay now um
when you have a look at this what are
you going to do like you can answer
questions face of this i like to say i
came here i like to say joy yourself up
rough set of actors you can see there's
a bit eccentric motion right what's the
center of motion just read that off the
equation the center of motion is just
this constant at the front so if you
want to say one two there's your Center
aversion what's my amplitude it's this
coefficient here which is one so I'm
going to be between one and three that's
where I'm waving in between okay now do
I start at the bottom or the top of
version cuz oh how do I know it's the
bottom surface so number one you can
taste the reflected cause graph so Brett
usually that was two plus it's just the
normal which start to the top comes down
but I've just moved the whole thing up
but I'm reflected the other way if you
get confused by that just put t equal 0
just put t equal 0 that'll be 2 minus 1
which is one and then you say oh ok well
therefore I found at the bottom now I've
got
up and down and up and off you go okay
so obviously you get asked questions
about that how long does it take to pass
the origin what's the maximum speed etc
you can work that out okay